so at the moment most of you have and at
this point if you haven't finished your
8 circles now is the time to finish your
eight circles but most of you have a
whole bunch of circles on your page
importantly always have a look at a
couple that are next to each other now
in our circle here I'd like you to also
plot the middle of your circle if you do
that for me
thank you now we already said right at
the top if we had a full revolution a
full revolution like so we used to call
you that how many degrees again 360 good
we're familiar with this right so if we
had a full revolution in a new kind of
way of measuring angles how could we
measure it thank you mrs. Lee's in a way
that might be well have different
advantages okay now here's what I'd like
you to do where you've drawn all your
circles
I'd like you to label the fact that
every single one of these I want them to
be a unit circle it doesn't matter if
they're all different sizes let's just
call them a unit circle if they are yeah
it doesn't matter it's okay it's fine
unless you're really messy which case
you should definitely pencil that's
right if all of these are unit circles
right the unit refers to like one unit
what does that mean on the on this
particular circle what is one unit on
here the radius thank you very much on a
unit circle the radius is one unit right
now I want you to figure out this
carefully with me if the unit circle has
a radius of one unit what is its
circumference what is the circumference
of the unit circle think about it for a
second think about for a second okay I
think I heard it I think I've had an
approximation if you wanna give me the
approximation it's about six point two
something six point two eight blah blah
blah blah blah where did we get that six
point two eight number from it it's pi
times the diameter now the diameter is
two because the radius is one so if you
went two times pi to pi that would give
you six point two a now that's an
approximation I really actually like to
write this exactly okay so if this is
the unit circle then you're going to
have
two pi whoops that's a bad you to play
units will be the circumference okay now
what I'm going to do is I'm going to
name this angle according to how far
I've gone around the circumference
according to that angle so see how I've
got two pi units I'm just gonna call
this angle 2 pi radians and I'm not
going to keep on writing radians because
it's a it's a long word I'm just going
to say Brad because radians aren't read
now that idea that the size of the angle
is related to how far along the
circumference I go you can see what I'm
trying to say is I want a new way of
measuring angles that deals better with
circles that's why I asked you to draw
on Cermak draw seven circles and I'm
about to draw another couple hundred
eighth okay so on this next circle what
I'd like you to draw is not 360 degrees
can you draw for me an angle that is
half a revolution do you go ahead and
draw that in you can do it on both so
here's our half revolution it's a
straight angle which of course makes it
based on the fact that our revolution is
360 degrees this angle is going to be we
know this we don't especially thank you
sir you still awake unlike everyone else
at the moment seemingly 180 degrees
fantastic now I can save this same angle
in radians I know you could probably
calculate it on the basis of this
pattern but again I want you to think
I'm going to name the size of this angle
based on how far does this angle take me
around the circumference now this is
still a unit circle
how far is half of the circumference
have a look at what's up it's it's just
yeah it's just half of that right
because it's the whole circumference so
it's going to be hold on think about it
half of this remember there's a PI hang
around there right so it'll be one pi so
I'm going to write that as PI units
okay so if I've gone PI units around the
circle then I'm gonna call this angle pi
radians okay now this you're sort of
starting to see where I'm going what I'd
like you to do on the third pair of
circles is can you do me a right angle
do it four degrees do it four radians
and then the last one this one is gonna
take some foot so just pause for a
second like keep your bit of your hand
look up cuz I want you to understand
what I'm asking you in the last pair of
circles we've done two parodies we've
done PI radians you're about to do I'm
not going to tell you how many radians
but a right angle on the last pair of
circles I want you to try and work out
what would one Radian look like this is
a whole unit so this is sort of the
point of me going through this process
right how big would one Radian if that's
two pi radians how big would one look
like so have a go through do your right
angle while your next set of circles and
see if you can work out how would I do
one rated on the last one I'll give you
some time to work on that while I make
some new circles and draw up yeah but I
don't spoil it for you all right so
you're saying to go to that point you're
thinking you're like mmm some of you
have some good guesses some of you are
on the right track this is actually a
really important moment where you're at
that point of I'm still feeling a little
lost what's the piece that could fit
this together right so let's do the
right angle first cuz I think most
people are comfortable with this in
degrees land we would call of course a
right angle 90 degrees great but over
here when we think about this the
question you should be asking your head
is how far around the circumference have
I gone for a right angle and the answer
is well I've gone a quarter of the way
around I've gone the full way I haven't
gone halfway I've just gone a quarter of
the way so it'll be a quarter of this or
half of this so instead of writing to PI
or PI I'm going to write how far around
the circumference PI over two that's how
many units I have gone around the
circumference using this angle and so
therefore I named that angle based on
that distance PI on two radians okay
if you've ever picked up someone else's
math textbook or you've flipped through
in too far into Cambridge you're like
wow
where all these pi is going on and PI on
to is an angle that comes up a whole lot
because it's 90 degrees and angle you
use a heck of a lot all right now then
the last one this mystery one right
we're trying to get through what we know
what a degree is we know what 90 of them
look like what does what does a Radian
look like you got to information on here
that can help you out right for example
every time you have a look at one of
these conversions for instance if I told
you that a foot equals let's actually
use a proper abbreviation here if I set
a foot equals 12 inches you could use
that to work out what 1 inch was in feet
you could use this to work out what a
single inch is in feet if I wanted not
12 inches but one edge what would I do
to both sides think carefully
yeah to get to go from here to here I
divided by 12 so did that to the right
hand side I should do that to the left
as well that would give me 1/12 so that
should say 1 of a foot right now think
about that you actually got three
opportunities to do this you should get
the same answer out for all of them for
reasons it'll become clear in a second I
think you'll find this one this is
second one here the easiest one tell a
look at it right if you've got a hundred
eighty degrees being the same as pi
radians that's actually worth writing
down 180 degrees equals pi radians if I
didn't want high-rated that's about
three in a bit I just want one of them
just like here what should I do to both
sides I should divide by PI that will
give me one Radian okay now PI's a bit
of a gross number but your calculator is
quite good at gross numbers so get your
calculator out and would you please
punch in when you divide both sides by
PI over here I'm going to get 180 over
pi now it should give you a nice decimal
expansion I'm expecting it's about fifty
seven point two nine degrees dot right
so that's that's pretty close now what
does 57.2 day look like if you want to
eyeball it it's close enough to 60 I
mean
eyes on a circle of this size right you
probably can't tell three degrees all
that much so if your eyeball 60 you've
got to get pretty close to it but
importantly you're not going to get
exactly it circles have this weirdness
built-in so the pie is a very strange
and unusual number so radians are going
to be a bit strange and unusual as well
because they're so closely leaved to
circles so here's what we're going to do
a fireball 60 I think it's gonna be
about was about two-thirds the way up to
a right angle right so I'm gonna go
there not that should have been fine
let's try that again
maybe more like not that's too high a
trained professional would have bought a
protractor with them but I don't have
one now I'm gonna be satisfied with that
it's the difference so this is about I'm
going to call it about fifty seven point
two nine degrees but if I wanted to
write it precisely this angel is pot
sorry 180 degrees divided by PI 180 on
Pyun if you want you can say that's
approximately fifty seven point two nine
degrees okay now come over here I'm
gonna draw the same angle roughly and
what did I say that was in radians
what was the angle we would try to work
out just exactly what radio right thank
you very much
wrong Tala one Radian now all the way
through first second third pair of
diagrams and now this last pair the
whole point of a radius to think about
how far you've gone around the
circumference right so you have this arc
over here if the angle is one Radian how
far around the edge of the circle will
you have got figure out this right the
the the rad the radio right is our
measure of like how far if you sort of
like like turned your angle right but
this thing here is just a length right
the units I've been using are well I've
been using units because I don't know if
they're centimeters or inches or
whatever so it's just one of those
that's how far I've gone around right
now remember we started off by saying
all the wave unitize to come
is about 6.3 does this not look about
one sixth of that that's why it's
exactly what unit